hey guys it's jenna here in my previous
video i shared some of my results from
my genetic tests i did with circle dna
in this video i'm going to dive in a
little deeper to find the right diet for
your body type if you have been eating
well and exercising regularly yet you're
not getting the results you're looking
for perhaps you are still unknowingly
doing the wrong thing for your body type
some of you might have even tried all
the diets out there low fat low carbs
high fat high protein but nothing seems
to work and you just don't know what to
do
not every diet suits everyone if you
want to see effective results the diet
you choose needs to be optimal according
to your genetics so based on my circle
dna results my optimal diet is healthy
balance there are four categories in
this section depending on your results
you might fall under low carb low fat
mediterranean or healthy balance so how
do we determine this
if you look under fat sensitivity and
carb sensitivity both my results are
normal this means my body isn't highly
sensitive if i were to consume cups or
fats in my diet hence i fall under
healthy balance because i can't consume
them in moderation if however your
results show that you have a higher
sensitivity towards carbs but a normal
fat sensitivity then the optimal diet
type for you will be low carb on the
other hand
if you have a higher sensitivity towards
fat and a normal cup sensitivity then
the optimal diet type for you will be
low fat
if
your results show that you have a higher
sensitivity towards both carbs and fats
then the optimal diet type for you will
be mediterranean so based on your
results how do you then cook and eat
according to the diet recommended to you
before i share the meal suggestions if
you haven't yet done your dna test and
you're curious about your body type go
to circledna.com to find out more about
the different services they offer you
can use the coupon code joanna at
checkout to get one kit for 35 off two
to three kids for 40 off and four or
more kids for 50 off
this is applicable to any circle dna kit
you purchase and this offer is only
limited to the first 100 kids sold so do
share this information with your family
and friends let's take a look at the
four diet types and the meal suggestions
let's start with my optimal diet which
is healthy balance if you fall under
this category you are lucky because your
body tolerates fats and carbs well hence
the recommendation is to consume
everything in moderation your healthy
plate should look like this
half vegetables quarter protein and
quarter cups fill your plate with a
variety of colorful vegetables as they
are a great source of vitamins minerals
antioxidants and dietary fiber you can
also add a piece of fruit into your meal
as for protein go for high quality
proteins such as chicken fish meat
tempeh tofu beans legumes and yogurt the
general recommendation is about 0.8
grams of protein per kilo of your body
weight but if you are active then you
should be consuming between 1.2 to 1.7
grams of protein per kilo of your body
weight for example i'm 50 kilos and
because i'm active i would consume about
1.5 grams of protein per kilo of my body
weight that means i should eat about 75
grams of protein a day how i would
achieve that is to consume 2 eggs for
breakfast one portion of salmon for
lunch and
one portion of white fish for dinner
that gives me a total of 72 grams of
protein
you need enough protein to perform
strength training and to build lean
muscle mass
based on my nutrition report i have a
higher need for iodine omega-3 dha
vitamin b12 and vitamin b6 hence i
follow a pescetarian diet and will
consume oily fish such as salmon tuna or
mackerel at least three to four times a
week if you are a vegetarian or vegan
you can also consider taking supplements
if you find meeting your daily
requirements from food alone is
difficult as for carbohydrates choose
healthy complex cups such as rice quinoa
oats buckwheat noodles sweet potatoes
pumpkin whole grain pasta or wholemeal
bread i have been following a healthy
balanced diet for several years now and
i have seen great results i have enough
strength and energy for my training and
i've also improved my body composition
by reducing my body fat and increased my
total lean muscle mass let's have a look
at the low carb diet if you fall under
this category that means you have a
higher sensitivity towards cups and your
body has a high resistance to insulin
insulin is the hormone responsible for
controlling your blood sugar levels a
high level of insulin resistance means
that your blood sugar levels are likely
to spike after consuming cups especially
refined cups
some of the common signs of cup
sensitivity include an intense craving
for refined cup foods such as sweets
bread pasta biscuits cereals and cake
struggle with never really feeling full
which can lead to overeating energy
level tends to dip after an hour of
consuming cups
they tend to gain weight easily and they
experience carbohydrate withdrawals such
as headaches irritability mood swings
and anxiety
carb sensitivity is a real thing and it
might be the reason why weight loss can
be challenging for those who fall under
this category this doesn't mean that you
cannot consume carbs at all but you need
to choose the good cups and limit the
portion so if this is you here's how you
can make adjustments to your meals
first thing is to eliminate all refined
cups in your diet only go for healthy
complex cups such as quinoa oats
buckwheat brown rice sweet potatoes
pumpkin and beans next
limit your cup intake to about 100 to
150 grams per day here's an example of
how to portion our cups in your meals
half a cup of oats for breakfast
one small bowl of cooked brown rice for
lunch and around 150 grams of sweet
potatoes for dinner including the
vegetables you add into your meals
you're told total cup intake for the day
will be about 110 to 150 grams of cups
to feel satisfied and reduce your
cravings you can increase your protein
and non-starchy vegetable intake when
you're cup sensitive consuming carb rich
foods has a greater impact on your
overall well-being than merely reducing
your calorie intake so you have to pay
more attention to the types of carbs you
consume
if your optimal diet is low fat then
following a high fat or keto diet just
won't work for you having a higher
sensitivity towards fat does not mean
you cannot consume fats in your diet the
importance with a low fat diet is to
differentiate between the types of fats
since fat sensitivity is specifically
linked to saturated fats so you will
want to limit the amount of saturated
fats and choose unsaturated fats instead
saturated fats are found in animal
products such as red meat skin of
poultry full-fat dairy products eggs
cheese cream butter ghee lot and even
tropical oils such as coconut oil and
palm oil consuming too much of saturated
fats can increase ldl the bad
cholesterol levels unsaturated fats are
considered heart healthy they are
typically found in plant foods such as
avocados olives nuts and seeds as well
as fatty fish such as salmon mackerel
and tuna consuming more unsaturated fats
can help to reduce ldl levels and
increase hdl for good cholesterol
typically a low fat diet follows a
higher carb more protein and low fat
thai plan this means that 55 to 60 of
your calories can be from cups
20 from protein and the remaining 20 to
25 from fats
in general following a predominantly
plant-based diet would be suitable for
you
without making it too complicated here
are few simple guidelines to follow in
reducing your saturated fat intake trim
off any visible fat from meats and
remove skin from poultry before cooking
consume more plant-based foods which are
rich in protein and cups such as beans
peas lentils tempeh and tofu avoid
deep fried foods
choose healthier cooking methods such as
baking roasting steaming boiling or
poaching
avoid fatty and processed meats such as
bacon sausage ribs and luncheon meats
if you want to eat red meat then limit
it to only two to three servings per
week and choose leaner cuts
and the final diet type is mediterranean
if you have a higher sensitivity towards
both carbs and fats then this would be
the recommended diet for you as it is
low in cups low in saturated fats and
higher in unsaturated fats
i visited greece several years ago and
stayed there for a month i absolutely
love their way of eating i love the
flavors and it was really wholesome and
satisfying someone who follows a
mediterranean diet typically consumes a
wide variety of vegetables whole grains
fish seafood olive oil nuts seeds
legumes and potatoes
they would consume poultry eggs cheese
and yogurt in moderation and rarely
consume red meat they limit their
consumption of soft drinks processed
meats or refined grains
olive oil is the primary source of added
fat in the mediterranean diet they would
use it in their cooking instead of using
butter they would also substitute red
meat for seafood poultry or beans they
do also enjoy a variety of cheese in
small quantity and plain yogurt the
mediterranean diet is a delicious and
healthy way to eat
this diet is also suitable for me as it
meets my higher needs for oily fish once
again it's important to recognize that
our body type is not a life sentence
your body type will shift based on your
lifestyle activity and diet
modifications by understanding your
genetics you will be able to make the
right diet choice suitable to you rather
than blindly following a diet trend out
there do you know what's the optimal
diet for you let me know in the comments
below to find out more about your body
type go to circledna.com and key in the
coupon code joanna to get up to 50 off
links are in my description box below if
you enjoyed this video and find the
information to be extremely useful then
do share it with your family and friends
in my next video we will discover more
about the right type of exercise you
should be doing according to your body
type so be sure to stay tuned and do
also subscribe to my youtube channel for
a lot more workout videos nutritional
tips and fitness tips all the best